[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen
maybrit illner heißt heute ausnahmsweise
theo koll der vertrauten gastgeberinnen
dieser runde die nada corona positiv
getestet wurde wünschen wir einen milden
verlauf und gute genesung die ukraine
kämpfen jetzt schon seit genau drei
wochen um ihr überleben und um das ihres
staates sie fordern mehr hilfe und zwar
jetzt präsident selensky hat heute
morgen den abgeordneten des bundestags
eindringlich ins gewissen geredet ja sie
deutlich kritisiert und gemeint also
macht deutschland schon alles was
möglich wäre darüber wollen müssen wir
reden und zwar mit diesen gästen
andré melnik der ukrainische botschafter
fordert deutschland muss helfen den
himmel über der ukraine sicher zu machen
marie agnes strack zimmermann
die fdp verteidigungsexpertin sagt
selent kies rede im bundestag war eine
mahnung die ukraine in allem zu
unterstützen
erich fahrt der brigadegeneral ag hält
eine flugverbotszone für nicht sinnvoll
das wäre ein schritt in den weltkrieg
michael roth für den spd-politiker ist
klar wir dürfen uns von putin nicht
einschüchtern lassen und
robert habeck der vizekanzler sagt die
sanktionen treffen russland hart
sie sind zu gast bei theo koll
[Musik]
die kritik des ukrainischen präsidenten
heute im deutschen bundestag war klar
und unmissverständlich erinnerte an die
historische schuld deutschlands und
forderte ein größeres eintreten für die
freiheit der ukraine und europas wir
beginnen mit einigen bemerkenswerten
auszügen aus diesem appell gefolgt von
einem gespräch über diese rede und den
krieg dass ich kurz vor der sendung mit
vizekanzler robert habeck geführt habe
in diesen drei wochen sind viele
menschen gefallen
tausende ukraine die besitzer haben
schon 108 kinder getötet
jedes jahr wiederholen die politiker nie
wieder und jetzt sehen wir dass diese
worte einfach nichts wert sind in europa
wird ein volk vernichtet
sie sind durch eine art mauer von uns
getrennt es ist keine berliner mauer es
ist eine mauer inmitten von europa
zwischen freiheit und unfreiheit und
diese mauer wird größer mit jeder bombe
die auf die ukraine fällt
ein präsident der vereinigten staaten
ronald reagan hat mal in berlin gesagt
mister gorbatschow tear des wall down
zerstören sie diese mauer
und das sage ich an sie lieber herr
bundeskanzler scholz zerstören sie diese
mauer
geben sie deutschland die führungsrolle
die deutschland verdient damit ihre
nachfahren stolz sind auf sie
unterstützen sie den frieden
unterstützen sie die ukraine stoppen sie
diesen krieg helfen sie uns diesen krieg
zu stoppen es lebe die ukraine
herr vizekanzler sie waren heute im
bundestag und haben den ukrainischen
präsidenten gehört er wirft deutschland
unter anderem vor eine neue mauer
zuzulassen zwischen freiheit und
unfreiheit trifft sie dieser vorwurf
die rede von herrn sie lenski war
berührend verstörend anklang
und aus seiner sicht sicherlich komplett
berechtigt aus sicht der bundesregierung
und aus deutschland nicht komplett
berechtigt in deutschland tut viel um
die ukraine zu unterstützen und vieles
was für vor wochen noch für unmöglich
erachtet haben sein appell an den
bundeskanzler jahren die ganze
bundesregierung war sehr eindringlich
wie auch schon gestern in washington
oder auch in london ist eine art video
weltöffentlichkeit die da geschaffen
wird sehen sie darin aber auch die
gefahr dass der westen noch stärker in
den krieg eingezogen werden könnte beim
erst einmal zeigt dass hier haben es ja
auch gezielt dass die
anklage das muss man so sagen das war
sie ja die aufforderung der ukrainischen
regierung und von herrn vilimsky
eine ist die sich an die verschiedenen
länder richtet die ja unterschiedlich
helfen und unterschiedliche maßnahmen
ergriffen haben aber sich sehr gut
koordinieren und insofern und dass wer
wollte es ihm verdenken ich meine der
mann führt seit drei wochen einen krieg
in seinem land beziehungsweise
verteidigt sein land seine leute sterben
erweist dass er entgegen eine große über
machtkämpfe und wir haben natürlich auch
ich immer wieder telefonische kontakte
in die ukrainische regierung rein und da
ist immer wieder sehr große
kampfbereitschaft und ganz große
verzweiflung immer wieder da und das hat
sich ja in dieser rede auch
widergespiegelt und die grenze die
deutschland ja immer wieder zieht ist
genau die nämlich der ukraine alles zu
geben was sie stärkt was hilft aber dem
einen schritt der dazu führt dass wir
kriegspartei werden nicht zu gehen und
das mag auf seiner 60 wie verraten und
verkauft anfühlen muss das auch wäre ich
in der ukrainischen regierung ich will
nicht anders reden aber aus sicht der
deutschen der westlichen regierung ist
das halt eine notwendige grenze die wir
nicht überschreiten können dann haben
wir diese woche erlebt dass die
regierungschefs einiger nationen polen
tschechen slowenen in geheimer mission
nach kiew gereist sind der polnische
ministerpräsident fordert jetzt dass
auch der bundeskanzler und andere nach
kiel fahren sollen ihre solidarität zum
ausdruck bringen der französische
präsident mag rom hat am abend schon
einen besuch nicht ausgeschlossen sollte
nach ihrer meinung auch der
bundeskanzler fahren würden sie auch
fahren
ich bin mich die reiseplanung des
bundeskanzleramtes und kann nicht für
olaf scholz sprechen wenn es einen
beitrag leistet ich würde immer fahren
was halten sie denn von der polnischen
idee einer friedensmission in der
ukraine das definiert sich ja durch nato
soldaten auf ukrainischem boden
wenn es einen waffenstillstand gibt und
friedensverhandlungen und die ukraine
und russland nicht mehr aufeinander
schießen wird man sicherlich in
irgendeiner form mit internationalen
truppen diesen frieden überwachen müssen
oder auch absichern müssen erklären aber
un-truppen nicht nato-truppen das wird
man sehen was welche truppen oder welche
bündnisse dann klug sind immer
menschheit dass wir jetzt nicht
besonders nahe liege zu sein dass die
nato in der ukraine ein beitrag zum
frieden leisten denn der vorwurf auch
wenn an den haaren herbeigezogen ist von
putin gegenüber der ukraine ist ja dass
sie sich der nato unterwerfen wollen
oder der nato land werden wollen
insofern scheint mir das jetzt auf den
ersten blick nicht besonders naheliegend
zu sein weil ich mir natürlich überhaupt
nichts ausschließen vor allem sind wir
da ja noch gar nicht sondern es muss
erst einmal das schießen und das tuten
gestoppt werden und das kann man nach
lage der dinge das ist schrecklich genug
auszusprechen nur über zwei maßnahmen
die ukrainer müssen standhalten und wir
unterstützen sie dabei wir liefern
weiter waffen an die ukrainische armee
und sie kämpft mit einer großen
opferbereitschaft mit einem
gut mit einem bei einem heroischen
booten muss man tatsächlich sagen gegen
diese große übermacht und russland putin
muss durch wirtschaftssanktionen hart
abgeschnitten werden so dass putin
gezwungen wird zu verhandeln und dann
muss man die verhandlungen absichern in
einer form über die ich nicht
spekulieren möchte ja wir haben sie denn
die sorge dass das besondere engagement
wir haben eben die polen gehört
einzelner staaten die nato in diesem
krieg ziehen könnte
die sorge ist da aber wir agieren ja so
dass aus der sorge keine wirklichkeit
wird das ist eben der unterschied zu der
rede des ukrainischen präsidenten dass
deutschland den schritt der es zum
kriegsland macht und das verbindet uns
mit allen nato ländern von den usa bis
zu polen eben nicht geht aber es werden
gibt es deswegen gibt es keine
flugverbotszone über der ukraine weil
dann nato truppen gezwungen wären
russische flugzeuge abzuschießen und
dann sind wir kriegspartei
kriegspartei mit einer atomaren
streitmacht dass das können wir nicht
wollen wie weit wie weit kann denn die
bundesrepublik gehen die usa 7 800
millionen für zusätzliche waffen ab wann
ist man eigentlich kriegspartei
kriegspartei ist man wenn eigene
soldaten auf andere soldaten schießen
oder eigene soldaten die waffen die
flugzeuge die panzer von anderen
abschießen
präsidentiellen ski wirft der deutschen
regierung ja vor dass es hier immer nur
um die wirtschaft gesagt wirtschaft
wirtschaft wirtschaft und dass wir
deshalb bei den sanktionen so zögerlich
seien sie haben dagegen auf den
ansonsten gefährdet den sozialen frieden
im land hingewiesen ist uns der aber
wichtiger als die freiheit des nachbarn
herr präsident sie lenski hat das in dem
kontext von noch stimmt 23 gaspipeline
durch den ort sie gesagt und hat quasi
wörtlich zitiert was der standpunkt der
vorgänger bundesregierung hin und zwar
der letzten in der großen koalition in
verschiedenen konstellationen immer
wieder war die gesagt hat dass es ein
rein wirtschaftliches projekt
das war es nicht das war falsch das ist
ja inzwischen auch eingeräumt und
zugegeben
und man muss es verlängern
energiepolitik ist nicht rein
wirtschaftlich zu betrachten wir leiden
darunter und haben auch nur eine
gebremste solidarität weil wir mit
gebundenen händen im moment für die
ukraine kämpfen können weil wir uns die
hände selbst gebunden haben durch die
große energiepolitische abhängigkeit von
russland also darauf hat er es bezogen
ansonsten muss man sagen dass die
deutsche wirtschaft ohne klagen die
sanktionen mitträgt und das sind der
sanktionen die auch investitionen
russland arbeitskräfte produkt ketten
damit gewinne und wirtschaftlichen
umsatz massiv schmälern ich bin dauernd
in den gesprächen mit den unternehmen
die haben natürlich dramatische verluste
teilweise aber da gibt es kein klagen
auch keinen rumlümmeln und sagen er
macht ein bisschen weniger sanktionen
ganz im gegenteil die sind bereit immer
auch weitere schritte zu gehen und
suchen diese schritte auch und gehen
auch über die sanktionen hinaus also
darauf bezieht sich dafür auf des
präsidenten nicht sondern auf eine
völlig falsche einschätzung was
energiepolitik eigentlich ist nämlich
bestandteil der nationalen souveränität
nun versuchen sie uns gerade bei der
energiepolitik ja zu entfesseln von
russland sie waren gerade norwegen am
wochenende reisen sie nach katar statt
fossilem entzug sucht deutschland sich
gerade neue dealer schrieb jemand eher
flapsig aber ab wann sind wir denn und
wie weit gehend energieunabhängig
wir müssen den fossilen in zug mit
großer geschwindigkeit fortsetzen das
ist in der tat so dass darüber zu wenig
berichtet wird aber auch da unternehmen
wir große anstrengungen die
energieeffizienz die einsparung nach
vorne zu schieben und wir werden sehr
zeitnah auch in der parlamentarischen
debatte darüber hoffentlich abstimmen
dass deutschland sich vom gas fürs
heizen verabschiedet wie
austauschprogramme machen wie er es
nicht bei geld für die gebäudesanierung
fehlen lassen dass wir jede form von
energie die abwärme in den großen
highlights in den großen kraftwerken in
den industrie kraftwerken nutzen zum
heizen unserer häuser wir können also
wirklich vieles noch besser machen aber
daran wird eben zeitgleich gearbeitet
die berichterstattung ist natürlich
darauf fokussiert auf das was scheinbar
ein tabubruch ist oder deutschland noch
nicht hat der lng terminals und auf
einmal kommt das gas aus katar oder
norwegen also insofern ist die
beschreibung der abhängigkeit eine
medial verschobene würde ich sagen sie
trifft nur ein teil der wirklichkeit
sind schauen wir jetzt mal auf die
energie und das benzin das wir gerade
haben so teuer wie nie zuvor kommt der
tank rabatt von christian lindner in der
angekündigten form oder wird es eine
andere entlastung geben
naja ich bin kein prophet aber mich hat
das jetzt nicht überzeugt und immer
weniger leute sind davon überzeugt dass
der tank rabatt wie gedacht eine gute
idee ist das problem ist ein deckel und
wenn man einen deckel auf preise
einführt in einem marktwirtschaftlichen
system dann muss jemand über den deckel
hinaus ja was bezahlen das ist quasi die
einleitung die einladung zum beutezug
gegen den staat in den öffentlichen
haushalt aber sie sind vizekanzler
würden sie es stoppen oder nicht wir
sind in gesprächen und das gute an
dieser koalition ist das wenn wir das
gut machen wir in gesprächen miteinander
reden und dann finden wir ein gutes
paket das vor allem in diesem fall
großen bestandteile für energie
effizienz und reduktion von verbrauch
von fossilen energien in deutschland
haben wird und das heißt ich verstehe
sie richtig das ist anders als das was
christian lindner vorgeschlagen hatte
wir sind ja im gespräch ich danke ihnen
für unser gespräch herzlichen dank
soweit der vizekanzler herr botschafter
sie waren auch heute im bundestag auch
sie wurden mit applaus bedacht von den
abgeordneten aber haben sie das den
eindruck dass durch diese rede die
haltung der bundesregierung wirklich
verändert wird der vizekanzler klang ja
eben nicht so
sehr für uns war wichtig dass dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen vom bundestag
diesem wunsch zugestimmt haben dass man
überhaupt reden durfte und dass er sich
auch in die deutschen an die politiker
in diesem land sich wenden er konnte um
sich zu bedanken auch für für die hilfe
die schon da war auch für die hilfe für
die flüchtlinge die gehen müssen und die
hier sehr warm und warmherzig
aufgenommen werden was ihre frage
betrifft natürlich haben wir uns
gewünscht dass nach dieser nach diesem
appell eines präsidenten und er hat
diese rede selbst geschrieben
dass auch die regierung sich äußerte
vielleicht auch der bundeskanzler
weitere pläne vorlegt was was die
ampelkoalition
vorhat um weiterhin uns unter die arme
zu greifen
es ist noch nicht so spät dass sich die
entscheidung der regierung waren man es
zur hauptsache dass diese hilfe ankommt
und zwar so schnell wie möglich der aml
sei ja relativ kritisch auch sie sind ja
für einen diplomaten er undiplomatisch
in ihrer rhetorischen gangart glauben
sie dass sie nur dadurch deutschland zu
einer politischen veränderung bringen
können
also wir
versuchen zu erklären worum es geht
integrieren und das was wir spüren ist
dass das nicht immer ankommt oder man
hat schon am 27
februar zum teil
begriffen dass dass dieser krieg jetzt
in der ukraine toppt aber dieser krieg
uns alle auch die deutschen betrifft und
zwar unmittelbar nicht nur was die
preise betrifft und wir glauben dass
worum es jetzt geht im moment erste
einfach den menschen zu erklären sind
politikern aber auch den einfachen
menschen in diesem land dass das was
putin wirklich vorhat geht weiter hinaus
über die ukrainischen grenze und dieses
risiko ist leider da auch wenn man sich
heraushalten möchte aber betonen
möchte das anders sehen und deswegen
wenn man uns hässlichen wählen sie auch
deutliche worte
also das sind keine deutlichen worte
sondern das ist eindringlichkeit ja die
die man einfach auf den tag legen müsste
waren sonst wir haben seit jahren ich
persönlich bin seit sieben jahren als
botschafter da und ich meinen ersten
tagen hier in berlin habe ich diese
these vertreten putin möchte die ukraine
vernichten er bereitet sich auf einen
neuen krieg seite grimma aktion vor und
das muss man auch ernst nehmen das war
unsere botschaft aber sehr sicher nicht
immer angekommen oder oder wurde auf die
leichte schulter genommen und darum geht
jetzt fraktionen sie waren auch heute im
bundestag was hat sie an dieser rede
besonders bewegt
dass ein präsident aus einem
kriegsgebiet spricht
und wir im warmen sitzen ich merkte auch
in meinen kolleginnen kollegen das
berührt sehr man aber auch eine gewisse
hilflosigkeit in dem moment hat
ich fand es gut ich habe mit noch
deutlicheren worten gerechnet ich fand
dass er sehr deutlich wahr war auch sehr
diplomatisch deutlich also ich hatte
verbal noch mit heftigen worten
gerechnet und wie gesagt das macht ein
fassungslos und
man ist
1300 kilometer weg das ist ja nicht viel
und dann rückt das natürlich wirklich
ran und ich muss sagen dass es auch
geradezu ein wunder ist dass aus dieser
unmittelbaren bedrohung und
bombardierungen ist überhaupt noch
möglich war dass der präsident
sowohl persönlich als auch technisch
möglich war in den bundestag zu senden
das wäre ja vor jahren gar nicht möglich
gewesen erleben wir da eine eine neue
form von
diplomatie oder auch von kriegsführung
also das was der präsident macht in
washington in london und so weiter ist
ja im prinzip auch
eine form von ich will diesen
kriegsführung aber jedenfalls von von
truppen sammeln naja kommunikation war
in den kriegen dieser welt immer
entscheidend früher hat man flugblätter
abgeworfen oder hat versucht überboten
geschichten zu erzählen die ein
kriegsverlauf verändern sollten das war
schon in der antike heute ist natürlich
durch die sozialen netzwerke durch die
möglichkeit auch trotz beschuss über
satelliten in kommunikation zu bleiben
natürlich die geschwindigkeit erhöht
aber dass kommunikation auch druck
erzeugt dass kommunikation auch seitens
russland fake news in das netz gestellt
werden also erzählungen was passiert und
das wissen wir aber wir wissen auch dass
aus kriegen auch durch journalisten auch
durch kolleginnen kollegen von ihm ja
wenn ich das sage live on unmittelbar
erzählt wird und berichtet wird das
macht es natürlich lässt es natürlich
unglaublich nahe kommen vor 20 jahren
hörte man von kriegen und oft wurde das
monate später erzählt jetzt ist man wenn
ich sage live dabei ist natürlich in der
türkei aufeinander schlagen so und
natürlich sind wir nicht live dabei weil
das ist hier nicht netflix wir gucken
nicht irgendein gruselfilm und
anschließend trinken wir was und denke
nach gott sei dank war nur ein film
sondern das ist knallharte realität ist
ein völkermord das ist barbarei und wir
erleben dass das eben vor unserer
haustür möglich ist und ich glaube wir
sind einer meinung dass keiner sich hat
je vorstellen können selbst wenn man
sich länger damit beschäftigt dass es so
jedweder
ja wie soll ich mal sagen zivilisation
bewegt herr roth die opposition wollte
ja nach der rede heute eigentlich eine
aussprache zur rede zur ukraine
das wurde abgelehnt von der ampel
norbert röttgen sprach von dem zitat
würdeloses im moment im bundestag den je
erlebt hat wäre so eine debatte riecht
heute zwingend gewesen im nachhinein war
das was wir heute morgen erlebt haben
sicher ein fehler ich mache da niemanden
einen vorwurf ich war nicht involviert
aber ich trage natürlich auch
mitverantwortung des hts dazu gekriegt
wir hatten gestern eine intensive
debatte im bundestag über die lage in
der ukraine an der auch ich beteiligt
war und die außenministerin annalena
baerbock führte aus es sehr gut wenn man
dieser rede zuhört und sie stehen ließe
ich habe dann auch gehört dass wir in
den seltensten fällen besondere gäste
haben die eine rede vor dem deutschen
bundestag halten und es bislang keine
aussprache gegeben hat aber wir merken
ja dass es in der gesellschaft ein
großes bedürfnis gab diese rede zu
verknüpfen mit reaktionen aus dem
bundestag aus der regierung heraus das
hätte man sicherlich besser machen
können aber ich würde jetzt dazu raten
und da bin ich auch ganz beim
botschafter uns daran zu messen was wir
jetzt tun und wir können und müssen mehr
tun um der ukraine zu helfen und nicht
irgendwann sondern jetzt man nur dann
wenn sie siegt die ukraine hat sie eine
chance zu überleben haben unsere werte
eine chance zu überleben und das ist
noch nicht in stein gemeißelt und dann
sagt ihre verteidigungsministerin frau
lamprecht heute dem ukrainischen
präsidenten weitere unterstützung in
aussicht gestellt wissen sie um was es
da geht ich halte überhaupt nichts davon
in der öffentlichkeit über details einer
solchen unterstützung zu sprechen dass
ihr werdet im zweifelsfalle unsere leute
und das gefährdet im übrigen auch unsere
freundinnen und freunde in der ukraine
ich bin kein experte aber was die
ukraine jetzt braucht sind einfache
waffensysteme die man schnell bedienen
kann die man vor allem auch sehr schnell
liefern kann und die dann dazu beitragen
dass sich die ukraine verteidigen kranke
strukturen sie
verteidigungsexperten und sie haben
sofort nach der rede geschrieben die
ukraine mit allem was wir geben können
zu unterstützen
wir hatten ja drei wochen lang eine
diskussion über defensiv und offensiv
waffen ich glaube dass gott sei dank
diese diskussion beendet ist
aber um ihre frage zu beantworten sie
jetzt gerade nicht an mich gestellt habe
aber es gibt eine nationale
sicherheitsrat in dem weder sie noch ich
drin sitzen und das macht auch sinn dort
wird das entschieden denn eins ist klar
ich verstehe natürlich das mediale
interesse gibt ja auch erstaunlich viele
sogenannte spezialisten die auf mein
büro anschreiben an sollte doch die ware
liefern und die das finde ich ein
bisschen befremdlich denn diese waffen
müssen angeliefert werden absolut aber
sie müssen auch von menschen geliefert
werden und sie sind natürlich damit auch
ein mögliches ziel eines luft beschusses
also auch die die das dorthin
transportieren kann man nicht sagen das
passiert jetzt die grenze und die grenze
insofern finde ich es auch befremdlich
darüber zu sprechen ich glaube wichtig
ist was am ende passiert nämlich dass
die waffen geliefert werden dass sie
handelbar sind und dass sie dort
ankommen wo sie auch unmittelbar
eingesetzt werden können die garde
general ade sie haben lange kanzlerin
merkel beraten
die usa geben jetzt weitere 800
millionen frei für waffenlieferungen
ist das der richtige weg und ist man
dann schon kriegspartei sie haben eben
als vizekanzler das definierte
offensichtlich nicht ganz zugestimmt
dass man nur dann kriegspartei ist wenn
man selber schießt
also ich glaube dass sie die grenzen
sind einfach fließen nicht dieses 800
millionen paket ist natürlich etwas ist
eine gewaltige masse auch an material
auch an wer material was geliefert wird
und ich habe immer gesagt wenn man
waffen liefert ist man zwar die jure
noch keine kriegspartei befindet sich
auf dem weg dorthin zur konfliktpartei
irgendwann zur kriegspartei auch in der
wahrnehmung des anderen das hängt ja
auch davon ab es ja nicht nur eine klare
juristische definition sondern was denkt
der kontrahent darüber und wie definiert
er das am ende
es könnte einen rutschbahneffekt geben
und ich glaube man muss sich auch die
frage stellen was kommt nach diesem 800
millionen paket was kommt danach kann
man denn eigentlich also gegen eine
atommacht
sinnvollerweise krieg eskalieren
das ist schwierig also
sie haben die atomare möglichkeit die
nach der russischen doktrin kann man
eben auch atomwaffen in der kriegführung
einsetzen dass sie die nato anders
sie müssen das immer einkalkulieren sie
können halt eine atommacht müssen sie
anders behandeln stichwort
flugverbotszone das kann man machen wir
haben das ja gemacht im irak auf dem
balkan in libyen das kann man machen
gegenüber einem militärisch relativ
schwachen herausforderer der ein paar
luftfahrzeuge hat das kann man aber
nicht gegenüber anders machen weil sie
dann natürlich sofort letztlich
kriegspartei sind da rutscht sie
förmlich rein machen sie sich jetzt im
konkreten fall sorge dass es zum einsatz
von atomwaffen kommen könnte also man
muss abwarten aber ich bin sicher wenn
putin mit dem rücken an der wand steht
und da nichts mehr passiert und insofern
muss man krisenmanagement betreiben dann
könnte er versucht zahlen zur atomaren
eskalation zu schreiten ja das ist eine
gefahr in der wir leben weil wir in
einer konfrontation mit einer
nuklearmacht sind und nicht mit
afghanistan irak libyen syrien das ist
eine andere qualität herr botschafter er
macht im moment städte in ihrem land dem
erdboden gleich oder zumindest
[Musik]
teile davon man traut ihm den einsatz
von chemiewaffen zu gleichzeitig sage
sie und auch ihr präsident dass der
einsatz von atomwaffen nur ein bluff sei
was führt sie den zu der annahme
und wir glauben nicht dass putin ein
selbstmörder ist denn atomwaffen
einzusetzen bedeutet wahrscheinlich für
ihn aber auch für russland für die
gesamte welt
ja ein cs ende und das ist nicht das was
er anstrebt ich möchte in die geschichte
eingehen um diese geschichte muss noch
von jemandem geschrieben werden das ist
unsere einschätzung und wir glauben
nicht dass diese waffen die gott sei
dank die amerikaner in diesem umfang
jetzt gestern gebetet haben
dass sie nicht zu einer weiteren
eskalation führen werden da sind vor
allem stinker und evelyn anti panzer bzw
abwehrraketen und mit diesen waffen kann
man dieses folgen der russen dieser
bodenoffensive zu bestücken bringen das
geschieht schon heute mit den waffen die
wir allmählich bekommen von unseren
partner und
darauf kommt es an es kommt darauf an
dass putin nur dann bereit sein wird
ehrlich und ernsthaft zu verhandeln wenn
er dazu gezwungen wird wenn seine
generelle ihm endlich ein stück wahrheit
sagen es ist die zeit gekommen man
sollte darüber reden und deswegen muss
dann müsste man sich nicht von dieser
angst jetzt leiten lassen und
und bangen ob wir jetzt wirklich putin
wenn wir was tun und dann wird er
weiterhin eskalieren braucht keine
weiteren provokationen alles was diese
krieg war nicht provoziert schon gar
nicht von uns oder von ihnen deswegen
man muss einfach das richtige tun und
das wichtig ist uns zu helfen und damit
die anderen nachbarn staaten auch
deutschland nicht als die nächsten ziele
während für für unter inkaufnahme eines
restrisikos
das risiko ist immer da aber wir haben
schon so viele jahre verzögerte zögerte
und abgewartet das hat uns nicht
geholfen von diesem krieg abzuwenden und
das muss man jetzt auch leider so klar
im ausdruck bringen frau strukturen der
nato generalsekretär hat jetzt
vorschläge zur dauerhaften verstärkung
der nato ostflanke gemacht in der nato
russland grund akte heißt es hier
dass die nato sich verpflichtet auf die
dauerhafte stationierung substanzieller
kampftruppen in östlichen bündnisgebiet
zu verzichten wird es doch dazu kommen
naja angesichts dessen was da passiert
wird natürlich auch eine grund akte in
frage gestellt alles andere wäre ja
seltsam die grundakten basierte ja
darauf dass man sich sozusagen nicht zu
nahe kam um den andere nicht das gefühl
zu vermitteln dass aus der nato die ein
reines verteidigungsbündnis ist ein
aggressor wird aber angesichts dieses
massenmordes und dieses unvorstellbare
angriff auf die zivilbevölkerung
muss man natürlich darüber nachdenken
und ich begrüße dass das die ostflanke
der nato oder geht es ja um länder wie
polen und die baltischen staaten
rumänien bulgarien die er unmittelbar an
russland an grenzen und natürlich zu
recht auch sorge haben dass dieser krieg
auch sie übergreifen könnte dass man
genau darüber denkt wir haben ja lange
diskutiert weil die nato ja ein bild
hatte dass russland mit am tisch sitzt
das ist das wäre ein anderes thema das
china weit weg ist und es ist ja wichtig
dass ein solches bündnis was übrigens
nicht hirntot ist sondern gerade zeigt
dass es zusammen steht aber so
realistisch ist dass es sich eben den
gegebenheiten anpasst und auch antworten
findet und deswegen halte ich das für
richtig
ich würde gern noch mal auf diesen
nachschub an waffen schauen der muss ja
im prinzip durch die west ukraine kommen
jetzt als militärischer lange liegt ja
nicht auf der hand dass man damit dann
auch zum angriffsziel wird im grunde
angriffe von putin in der west ukraine
provoziert auf solche nachschubs in
aschen lieferung naja die großen haben
erkannt dass die masse des nachschubs
natürlich über die west ukraine läuft
die seeblockade zum schwarzen meer ist
ja fast dicht ich meine wenn man oder
sie vielleicht aus nimmt da
kontrollieren die russen was übersee
reinkommt die über luft kann wenig rein
gebracht werden im moment auszuschließen
ist es nicht also die masse geht über
die west ukraine und natürlich sind die
russen schon nach meinen informationen
mit spezialkräften in der west ukraine
und sie kontrollieren natürlich auch
schon die die wege also sie haben ein
auge darauf geworfen auf die
versorgungswege nicht und je mehr
darüber jetzt rollt ja es gab ja jetzt
vor zwei tagen auch die ersten raketen
angriffe in dieser region auf einem
truppenübungsplatz und auf in der nähe
und das galt nach meiner meinung schon
diesen versorgungs wegen und werden
jetzt stärker je stärker die
waffenlieferungen laufen über die west
ukraine hier stärker wird dieser fokus
bei den russen seien genau das zu
verhindern mit raketen schlägen oder bis
hin zu der möglichkeit dass sie dort
auch tatsächlich mit dem boden
kampftruppen reingehen ich sehe das im
moment nicht weil sie zu wenig truppen
haben um die gesamte ukraine zu besetzen
aber auszuschließen ist das nicht als
weitere eskalation so gibt es heute
abend meldung
mit bezug auf einen hochrangigen
mitarbeiter des
verteidigungsministeriums in washington
die er zitiert wird es gebe hinweise auf
nachlassende kampfmoral bei den
einheiten russischer truppen gründe
seien fehlende informationen über sinn
und zweck des einsatzes und der harte
widerstand klingt das für sie
realistisch
naja der vorstoß der russen wir sind
jetzt haben jetzt drei wochen krieg sie
hatten schon beachtliche geländegewinnen
das muss man sehen also im süden ist es
ihnen gelungen an der schwarzmeerküste
bis nach odessa zu kommen und sie wollen
ja auch das aufnehmen und dann diesen
schluss nach transnistrien vermutlich
machen und am asowschen meer haben sie
die landverbindung hergestellt in den
dombach in mario pohl wird noch gekämpft
in ordnung aber die landbrücke ist da
dass man immer so die strategischen
ziele und die grossen urbanen zentren
sind eingekesselt oder kurz davor
eingekesselt zu sein kiew charkow und
und andere damit sind sie ziemlich weit
gekommen es gibt berichte darüber moral
der soldaten das stimmt soldaten die
panzer verlassen es gibt berichte über
logistikprobleme sie kommen ja auch aus
mehreren stoßrichtungen und die ganze
logistik muss dann entsprechend auch
verteilt werden und die russen stehen
vor dem großen dilemma jetzt
offensichtlich gibt es keinen kurzen
krieg soll das ist sondern man bewegt
sich eigentlich in einen lang lang
andauernden krieg hinein orts und häuser
kam vielleicht danach einen lang
andauernden guerilla krieg und das ist
das fatale die amerikaner haben auch im
irak innerhalb von zwei drei wochen die
irakischen streitkräfte zerschlagen
bagdad besetzt aber dann kann eigentlich
erst der krieg wir haben das in
afghanistan erlebt wir haben innerhalb
von zwei drei wochen die amerikaner die
taliban neutralisiert die
kommandozentralen ausgeschaltet das war
konventionell erfolgreich wir haben nach
20 jahren mit über 50 staaten beteiligt
dieses land verlassen als verlierer
besiegt von taliban mit turnschuhen und
kalaschnikow also klar die furcht dass
man gefahr läuft die dann mit diesen
meldungen dann doch im grunde die die
macht dieses militärapparates in
russland zu unterschätzen als die russen
glaube ich befürchte dass eben mit der
konventionellen krieg führung nicht mehr
weiterkommen und tatsächlich in einen
art lang hatten einen konflikt zu
gelangen auch in den städten nicht man
kann nicht so eine stadt in ein zwei
tagen frei kämpfen und nicht die
ukraine das hat sie mit sicherheit
überrascht haben eine hohe kampfmoral
wie sie sitzen in den städten drin und
warten auf den feind und sie werden
kämpfen nicht um ist eine wehr
motivation ohnegleichen nicht da müsste
sich deutschland mal so zehn prozent
davon wäre für uns auch ganz ganz gut
gleich angesichts des zustandes der
bundeswehr
als prognostiziert einen vom
schleppenden fortgang der invasion
frustrierter putin werde zitat versuchen
das ukrainische militär ohne rücksicht
auf zivile opfer zu zermalmen zitat ende
gibt es für irland so etwas wie eine
grenze an zivilen opfern die sie bereit
sind in kauf zu nehmen
ja so diese frage ist so zynisch dass
ich keine antwort darauf geben werde
denn das was uns jetzt vorgeworfen wir
wir sollten uns so schnell wie möglich
aufgeben ergeben weil die zivile opfer
so hoch sind
herr putin und russland sind dafür
verantwortlich und nicht wir und wir
werden wir werden diesen gefallen werde
unseren deutschen freunden machen noch
unseren amerikanischen freunden machen
nämlich uns zu ergeben und eben damit
sie diese schrecklichen bilder nicht
mehr ertragen müssen während ich würde
frage so habe aber ich bleibe aber es
ist ein volk und das ist meine antwort
auf ihre frage die frage ist dass wir so
lange kämpfen werden bis die
bodenoffensive von herrn putin zum
anstecken kommt das vorzeige general
fahrt geradeaus führt stimmt nicht ganz
gewiss nicht angetastet worden war gibt
es nicht angetastet wurden auf dem wege
nur nur die stadt mariupol wurde seit
zwei wochen angekettet worden und das
heißt das in der tat diese berichte die
sie erwähnt haben sie stimmen die moral
ist am boden es ist noch nicht so weit
ist die russin tatsächlich jetzt alles
verloren haben aber knapp 40% des
kriegsgeräts wurde entweder zerstört
oder einfach liegen gelassen auf den
feldern und von unseren fahrern in
besitz genommen sie haben knapp 14.000
soldaten verloren über 1000 gefangen
genommen wurden von uns und wenn man
vergleich mit dem was die amerikaner in
afghanistan oder im irak in 20 jahren
verloren haben das ist doppelt so viele
innerhalb von drei wochen und das ist
die antwort auf ihre frage ob die russen
das lange ertragen werden also diesen
dieser verlust wollen wir uns erst mal
genauer an in der ukraine läuft es für
putin nicht sehr gut aber auch die
einheit des westens bekommt erste risse
angriff auf das atomkraftwerk buschehr
es brennt der reaktor bleibt heil
die auswirkungen des krieges könnten
auch uns erreichen friedrich merz warnt
es kann eine situation geben in der auch
die nato entscheidungen treffen muss
putin zu stoppen
militäreinsatz
flugverbotszone das bedeutet krieg mit
russland
je länger der kampf dauert je größer die
zahl der opfer desto drängender diese
fragen
vorgestern die regierungschefs aus polen
tschechien und slowenien in kiel der
polnische vize regierungschef kaczynski
fordert hinterher
ich denke dass eine friedensmission der
nato oder einer breiteren
internationalen strukturen notwendig ist
aber eine solche mission muss in der
lage sein sich selbst zu verteidigen und
muss auf ukrainischem territorium
operieren kann
im klartext
nato-soldaten könnten vorrücken in die
ukraine für eine begrenzte
flugverbotszone haben sich auch 27
amerikanische außenpolitik experten
stark gemacht um fluchtrouten zu
schützen
darunter auch der ehemalige us
botschafter in berlin john kornblum
die nato lehnt das bisher ab
herr roth spaltet sich der westen gerade
in vorsichtige und den draufgänger
der westen die nato die europäische
union war so ist so geschlossen wie nie
das ist zwar ein schwacher aber immerhin
ein hinreichender trost in diesen
dramatischen traurigen zeiten und ich
kann nur davor warnen denn eine spaltung
nutzt nur herrn putin der das immer
wieder wie andere autoritäre regime auch
versucht hat uns zu spalten und damit zu
schwächen ich halte es aber für ganz
normal dass wer in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation wo es darum geht ein
angegriffenes land zu schützen
selbstverständlich auch darüber
diskutieren wie können wir das
bestmöglich und wir sagen ja auch zu
viel im jahr es ist richtig dass wir
jetzt mehr waffen liefern damit sich die
ukraine verteidigen kann es ist richtig
dass wir mehr humanitäre hilfe leisten
es ist richtig dass wir den geflüchteten
vorübergehend eine neue heimat geben es
ist richtig dass wir auch noch bei den
sanktionen drauflegen zur
flugverbotszone hat eben ja schon der
vizekanzler etwas gesagt und eine
friedensmission macht aus meiner sicht
nur dann sinnvoll wenn wir wirklich
endlich eine politische zusage haben das
ist zu einem waffenstillstand kommt dass
er dann auch überwacht wird und darüber
muss geredet werden und dauert zu müssen
dann die ukraine und russland ja sagen
aber alles andere als
sorgt bei vielen menschen auch angst und
ich finde wir dürfen uns jetzt auch von
putin nicht einschüchtern lassen das tun
wir seit 2008 seitdem er den georgien
krieg unterstützt hat dann 2014 die
völkerrechtswidrige annexion der krim
der krieg im osten der ukraine mit
unterstützung russlands und ich glaube
er droht auch deshalb nur mit den
atomwaffen weil er natürlich auch in
unserer eigenen bevölkerung diese
kritischen fragen sehnlichst erwünscht
und ich werde täglich danach gefragt ist
es verantwortbar die ukraine zu
unterstützen droht uns da nicht der
dritte weltkrieg und das müssen wir
politikerinnen und politiker jeden tag
gut begründen gegenüber einer
bevölkerung von der wir nicht erwarten
können dass sie die sprache die jetzt
zum beispiel ein ehemaliger general
spricht die für ihn selbstverständlich
ist auf anhieb versteht die macht vielen
menschen angst und das ist unsere
pflicht und schuldigkeit vielleicht auch
ein bisschen mit unterstützung der
medien da überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
die am ende menschen auch ihre sorgen
nimmt denn angst ist der schlechteste
ratgeber in einer solchen dramatischen
situation wir dürfen keine angst da
hätte man der ukraine eigentlich vor
jahren schon sagen müssen dass sie keine
möglichkeit hat in der nato aufgenommen
zu werden oder hätte man sie aufnehmen
sollen ja das ist eine gute frage
nächste standen die frage stand jahr
2008 an beim nato gipfel in bukarest ich
war selber auch dabei mit der kanzlerin
und es war gerade deutschland die gesagt
hat nein das ist einfach zu viel und wir
waren damals auch ziemlich allein die
nato wollte eigentlichen danach hat man
sich doch geeinigt auf zeit zu setzen
mit blick auf den membership action plan
und so weiter und sich einfach zeit zu
lassen im nachhinein sagen das war ein
fehler das weiß man nicht man weiß ja
nicht was putin gemacht hätte er ist ja
kurz danach
begann ja der krieg mit georgien recht
georgien stand auch auf der tagesordnung
aufgenommen zu werden und er hat ja dann
vollendete tatsachen geschaffen in
südossetien und abchasien einen großen
konflikt und damit zu verhindern dass
georgien überhaupt wieder überhaupt die
die chance hat mit der nato zu werden
das macht er jetzt mit dem dom bass mit
der ukraine aus seiner sicht auch
versucht das natürlich auch auszubremsen
ich denke aber wenn man realistisch ist
ich bin jetzt militärexperte kein
politiker aber ich denke mal die tages
auf der tagesordnung steht ja
nato-beitritt jetzt gewiss nicht das wie
sollte wie sollte das funktionieren also
der beitritt fraktion man in die
europäische union ist etwas was die
ukraine sich auch sehnlich wünscht wir
haben jetzt auf dem gipfel in versailles
die etwas schönfärberische formulierung
gehört die ukraine sei teil der
europäischen familie
ist es ein zurückweisen auf lange sicht
auf mittlere sicht oder wie schätzen sie
das nein das ist natürlich
wir haben es hier mit einem brutalen
krieg zu tun ich glaube diese
entscheidung dass die ukraine in die eu
kommt sollte nicht von diesen von dieser
situation abhängig gemacht werden es
gibt ein prozess länder aufzunehmen oder
die ukraine natürlich auch hervorragende
voraussetzungen und das wurde auch von
europa bereits bestätigt dass das auch
seine zeit braucht und nicht aus dieser
aus dieser nachvollziehbar aber sehr
emotionale situation heraus und ich
glaube dass wir alle
auch ein stück besonnen sein müssen das
ist ja ein ein schritt der sinn macht
der nachhaltig sein muss die europäische
union wächst und insofern dass man das
jetzt heute so artikuliert ja das ist
natürlich diplomatische sprache um der
ukraine jetzt nicht verbal
eine vom kopf zu hauen um das mal so
umzusetzen
aber das ist ein prozess bedarf der
eingeleitet werden muss ich meine schon
dass man auch an diesem prozess
festhalten solche botschaft sowie kommen
zu behindern
es war für uns schon eine gewisse
enttäuschung können das da
die entscheidung so aussieht wie sie
gerade formuliert haben denn ich glaube
dass deutschland hat auch da auf die
bremse getreten das wissen wir werden
dieses gipfels und es ist schade denn
man hat jetzt diese chance man sieht
dass die ukraine und da sagen die
deutschen selbst die ukraine kämpfen für
ihre werte für die freiheit für die
demokratie und
das ist auch die größte bedrohung für
putin so wird das hier interpretiert und
gleichzeitig wird uns der weg versperrt
diese politische entscheidung würde
nichts kosten deutscher steuerzahler und
laut umfragen die wir durchgeführt haben
sind über 60 prozent der deutschen für
einen eu beitritt der ukraine aber
natürlich in der perspektive und sind es
ist nicht so dass wir nicht uns
vorbereitet haben wir haben unsere
hausaufgaben seit 2004 10 ordentlich
gemacht und wir wollen auch keinen
freifahrtschein und wollen keinen rabatt
wir wollen nur ein ein beschleunigtes
verfahren das das nicht jahrzehnte
dauert wie für manche staaten sondern
vielleicht nur jahre und das ist eine
faire anfrage und bitte von unserer
seite michael roth also erst dann kann
ich die enttäuschung der ukraine
verstehen aber das was die staats und
regierungschefs und chefin beschlossen
haben ist mehr als einer dieser
typischen eu vorne kompromisse bislang
gab es für die ukraine überhaupt gar
keine perspektive es hieß wir machen
nachbarschaftspolitik und jetzt haben
wir die tür aufgestoßen aus nachbarn
sollen mitbewohnerinnen und mitbewohnern
des hauses europäische union werden und
ich würde uns auch angesichts der
probleme mit der nato
darauf verpflichten wollen dass wir das
wirklich ernst nehmen aber dann müssen
wir eben aus den fehlern lernen weil ich
kann natürlich die ukraine verstehen die
staaten des westlichen balkans haben
seit 2003 eine eu perspektive und es hat
sich noch nicht viel getan nicht nur
weil dort reform nicht gemacht worden
sind sondern weil wir die zusagen nicht
eingehalten haben und da finde ich hat
die ukraine schon anspruch auf ein
faires verfahren
ich glaube das wissen wir alle dass ist
langer wegen schwieriger weg aber ein
lohnenswerter weg denn wir können nicht
zu allem nein sagen wenn er denn
möglicherweise das mit der nato nicht
klappt und das war ja ist ja auch ein
verfassungsgemäßer wunsch der ukraine
dann sollte man das mit der
eu-mitgliedschaft ernst nehmen aber wir
sollten uns auch mal alle in die augen
schauen in der europäischen union das
ist nicht nur deutschland wollen wir das
wie wollen wir das und wie kriegen wir
das möglichst raschen aber auch um
deutlich zu machen wir sind eine
wertegemeinschaft wir sind ja nicht nur
ein binnenmarkt oder eine
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft wirtschaftsclub
und diese werte die werden jetzt von der
ukraine verteidigt und dazu muss man
auch noch etwas tun und sagen
rechtsstaatlichkeit
korruptionsbekämpfung aber es ist wert
es lohnt sich das heißt aber sie hätten
weniger auf der bremse gestanden als der
deutschen bundeskanzler ich weiß nicht
ob der bundeskanzler auf der bremse
gestanden hat ich weiß aber dass es ein
hochsensibles thema ist ich weiß dass es
grundsätzlich bei unseren französischen
freundinnen und freunden bei unseren
dänischen freundinnen und freunden auch
bei unseren niederländischen freundinnen
und freunden vorbehalte gibt wenn sie
mal im westlichen balkan fragen dann
wird deutschland immer als der ehrliche
makler wahrgenommen das war auch schon
mal bei der ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin
so das ist auch beim bundeskanzler
scholz so dass wir diese
beitrittsperspektive ernst nehmen wollen
weil sie ist das erfolgreichste modell
um ein land eine region zu befrieden so
demokratisieren und zu stabilisieren ich
gebe aber selbstkritisch zu dass wir zu
viele im westen und auch in der
europäischen union die ukraine und das
östliche europa eigentlich putins vorhof
der macht war wo wir uns möglichst nicht
einzumischen haben und damit ist jetzt
schluss herr botschafter ich würde gerne
mal auf das thema sanktionen schauen für
die ukraine zählt ja jeder tag
was aber nutzen sanktionen die
beispielsweise die
bundesrepublik wenn sie jetzt einen
sofortigen importstopp für öl gas und so
weiter verhängt gar nicht durchhalten
wird wir verstellen schon die sorgen und
wir haben
vizekanzler habe gehört man kann ihm das
ansehen ja wie stark er leidet unter
diesem druck eine moralische frage die
für uns alle hoffentlich mit ja
beantwortet werden kann und gleichzeitig
die situation in der sich deutschland
und andere europäische länder sich
befinden deswegen das was wir jetzt
anbieten als kompromisslösung man könnte
ein moratorium einführen als signal für
einen monat oder zwei monate man kauft
kein gas kein öl keine kohle und schauen
denn putin weiß dass er auch diesen
hebel hat das heißt wollte jetzt putin
eskalieren das weiß er schon von von
ihnen direkt dass die deutsche
wirtschaft womöglich kollabieren würde
oder dass dass der soziale frieden dann
gefährdet ist das heißt und man sollte
doch immer proaktiv agieren und nicht
nur warten und dann reagieren wo man
schon sowieso verloren hat das ist
unsere bitte an die bundesregierung also